die Warnlampen blinken rote in
Deutschland geht es wirtschaftlich
bergab des heizungsgesetz hat die Nation
und die Ampel durchgerüttelt die AFD ist
in Umfragen mittlerweile stärker als die
Kanzlerpartei und der Krieg in der
Ukraine ist zum ständigen Begleiter
geworden genug Gründe für ein Gespräch
mit dem Bundeskanzler und damit herzlich
willkommen zum ZDF sommerinterview
diesmal aus Potsdam
[Musik]
guten Tag Herr Bundeskanzler herzlich
willkommen zum ZDF sommerinterview moin
wir sind gar nicht weit von Ihrem
Zuhause entfernt genauer gesagt am
Potsdamer Olympiastützpunkt sie selber
Rudern auch regelmäßig ich habe gehört
auch hier am See und ist ja Rudern
politisch betrachtet etwas Kurioses
entweder man rudert und kommt vorwärts
schaut aber immer nur zurück oder man
ist Steuermann dann gibt man zwar den
Ton an aber macht sonst relativ wenig
was ist denn ihre Rolle im Ruderboot der
Region ich bin derjenige der den
das Tempo macht und das betrachte ich
auch als meine Aufgabe und
sorgt dafür dass es vorankommt dann
haben wir gerade erlebt wenn wir beim
Sport bleiben die Frauen
Fußballmannschaft ist ausgeschieden
schon in der Vorrunde folgt eigentlich
den erfolglosen Männern was ist denn los
mit dem ehemaligen Weltmeister
Deutschland es gibt ja viele
Fußballexperte und Experten in
Deutschland also zig Millionen ich hier
möchte mich aber nicht in die Reihe
derjenigen einreihen die alles besser
wissen als diejenigen die da tatsächlich
auf dem Platz stehen insofern aber es
läuft ja eigentlich nicht weitergegangen
ist und hätte den Frauen auch viel mehr
Glück und Erfolg gewünscht und die haben
ja auch sehr gut gespielt insofern ist
das natürlich nicht schön dass es sowas
gegangen ist mehr Erfolg braucht auch
die deutsche Wirtschaft und das ist
eines der Themen die wir jetzt
besprechen werden bitte schön
[Musik]
Bundeskanzler fast täglich Leuten die
Alarmglocken in der Wirtschaft wir haben
in Deutschland eine der höchsten Abgabe
Lasten bei steuern wir haben eine teure
Energie teurer als vielen anderen
Ländern der Welt wir haben überbordende
Bürokratie Fachkräftemangel aber sie
rechnen mit einem Wachstum wie beim
Wirtschaftswunder da passen doch Wunsch
und Wirklichkeit nicht zusammen ich habe
das bezogen auf die Möglichkeiten die
mit all den Investitionen verbunden sind
in den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
der Stromnetze der
wasserstoffnetze des der
Wasserstoffproduktion die wir in
Deutschland brauchen den Umbau viele
Teile unserer Wirtschaften das steht ja
auch alles konkret bevor viele planen
und wir sorgen dafür dass das jetzt auch
möglich wird mit einem ganz neuen Tempo
beim Ausbau der Strom Erzeugung über
windkraft und Solarenergie Biomasse
Wasserkraft und sie sprechen nur von
einem Patienten Wirtschaftswunder oder
nicht glaube dass das eine Wirkung haben
wird auf die ganze Wirtschaft was wir
jetzt erleben ist ja doch eine ganz
besondere Situation Deutschland ist
erfolgreich als Exportnation manche
Wirtschaftszweige exportieren 80 Prozent
dessen was sie hierzulande produzieren
und wenn wir noch ganze Unternehmen die
weggehen wenn dann anderswo das Wachstum
etwas schwächelt dann haben wir das
immer schon gemerkt aber man darf da
jetzt nicht das Kind mit dem Bade
ausschütten ich plädiere ausdrücklich
dafür dass wir weiter eine erfolgreiche
Exportnation Waren werden sein wollen
und alles dafür tun dass das so bleibt
Währungsfond hat uns gerade was ganz
anderes gesagt dass wir sind das einzige
Land das ein Minus vorhergesagt bekommen
vom internationalen währungsform braucht
es da nicht eine wirklich einschneidende
reformagender eine Agenda 20 30 was wir
brauchen ist dass wir die Probleme lösen
die wir wirklich haben dazu zählt zum
Beispiel dass wir anders als es ist als
wir eine große wirtschaftliche
Schwierigkeit hatten
ein Mangel an Arbeitskräften gibt und
nicht Arbeitslosigkeit als großes
Massenphänomen deshalb werden wir mit
all dem was wir an init Oliven ergriffen
haben für gute Ausbildungsplätze für
junge Leute
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten für schon
beschäftigte die sich in ihrer Firma in
den Betrieb weiterentwickeln können und
mit der Zuwanderung von Fachkräften
eines der von all den Wissenschaftlern
und Experten genannten Probleme real
lösen ich habe gerade diese Woche das
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetzes der
Bundestag beschlossen hat unterschrieben
es wird jetzt verkündet und dann werden
wir zum Beispiel diese eine
Voraussetzung für Wachstum in
Deutschland auch besser lösen können als
viele viele andere Länder nicht aus wir
brauchen jedes Jahr 400.000 zusätzliche
Arbeitskräfte wir beide stehen kurz als
Babyboomer kurz vor dem gesetzlichen
Rentenalter eigentlich bis 20 50
verliert der Arbeitsmarkt 12 Millionen
Menschen mehr als hinzukommen was fehlt
der noch an zusätzlichen Masse genau das
was wir gemacht haben mit den Maßnahmen
zur Einwanderung von Arbeitskräften die
wir in Deutschland dringend brauchen
damit genau das geschieht was Sie gesagt
haben wenn jetzt Pflegekräfte
dazu kommen doch mit dem was wir gemacht
haben kann das auch gelingen und wir
werden jetzt dafür sorgen dass nicht nur
das Gesetz da ist sondern dass auch die
Prozesse vereinfacht werden in denen das
dann für die Unternehmen gelingt und wer
sich einmal ein bisschen die Zahlen der
letzten Jahre anschaut sieht dass wir
das ja schon einmal hingekriegt haben
dafür mussten wir allerdings nichts
können denn die
fachkräftezuwanderung aus der
Europäischen Union ist einfach über die
Freizügigkeit möglich gewesen jetzt
müssen wir was können aber dazu genau
haben wir die notwendigen
Voraussetzungen geschaffen aber selbst
ihr Koalitionspartner FDP fordert ein
strategisches Konzept das heißt aber
doch im Umkehrschluss das gibt es nicht
doch es gibt einen strategisches Konzept
dazu zählt das was ich eben gesagt habe
dazu zählt auch dass wir strukturell
dafür sorgen dass die Stromerzeugung
dass die Energieerzeugung in Deutschland
billiger wird das gelingt mit dem Ausbau
der
Erzeugungskapazitäten und der Stromnetze
wir haben da ein unglaubliches Tempo
vorgelegt und viele Gesetze verändert
damit jetzt endlich so viel gebaut wird
wie wir tatsächlich auch brauchen man
sieht die Zahlen ziehen jetzt auch
richtig an das muss sein und darüber
hinaus glaube ich dürfen wir auch nicht
übersehen dass manches von dem was
gegenwärtig gesagt wird ein bisschen
eigenwillig wirkt während in Deutschland
die modernsten Direktinvestitionen
stattfinden die größte Direktinvestition
in der Geschichte Europas in Magdeburg
es findet eine massive ein Ausbau der
Halbleiterproduktion im Saarland statt
mit wolfspeed wir haben in Dresden
mehrere Unternehmen die dort schon sind
und weiter investieren der größte
Investor ist dort es gibt sehr viele
Wirtschaftsminister berichtet hat paar
in der Pipeline 80 Milliarden Euro
direkt Investitionen in Deutschland da
kann man doch
innehalten wenn in Deutschland dass der
Fall ist dass nachdem das Jahrzehnte
lang anders war in Europa der Halbleiter
Standort der Produktion funktioniert
jeden Arbeitsplatz in Dresden jetzt
gerade mit zwei einhalb Millionen Euro
das können sie doch nur sehr begrenzt
als Erfolg reklamieren vielleicht das
teile ich ihre Ansicht überhaupt nicht
ich glaube das ist eine bewusste
Entscheidung dieser Unternehmen die sind
nicht wegen der Subventionen die es auch
anderswo in der Welt gibt gekommen wir
dürfen auch gar nicht mehr machen als
was sie in anderen europäischen Ländern
auch gekriegt hätten sie haben sich für
den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
entschieden in dem batterie-fabriken
gebaut werden norfold haben wir gerade
gesehen der größte amerikanische
elektrofahrzeughersteller hat sich in
ganz Europa Deutschland als den Standort
für sein jetzt auch noch zum Ausbau
vorgesehenes Werk vorgesehen wir haben
milliardenschwere Investitionen z.B in
der Stahlindustrie und der
Chemieindustrie die dazu beitragen
sollen dass wir künftig CO2 neutral
wirtschaften können und das
ärgert mich auch in jedem
volkswirtschaftskurs lernen die
Studenten und Studenten dass der Erfolg
einer erfolgswirtschaft darin gesehen
werden kann dass ihre Unternehmen auch
im Ausland investieren nun muss ich ab
und zu hören und lesen dass das
angeblich schlecht sind
wir haben aber gleichzeitig auch den
teuersten Strom fast fünfmal teurer als
im Schnitt von 100 andere Nationen
Robert Habeck saskia ist nun viele
andere fordern deswegen ein
subventionierten Strompreis für
energieintensive Unternehmen sie lehnen
das bisher als dauerhaft ab gilt das
auch für nicht dauerhaft diese Pension
wir haben eine Hauptaufgabe die besteht
darin dass wir die Strompreise runter
kriegen strukturell dann wir werden ja
nicht in der Lage sein dauerhaft
Strompreise zu subventionieren und das
will ich ausdrücklich sagen wenn wir mit
dem Ausbau der Netze weiter als wir es
heute schon sind wäre das nicht liegen
geblieben wäre es im Südwesten
Deutschland so gewesen dass der Ausbau
der Windkraft auch schneller
vorangekommen wäre dann hätten wir jetzt
schon billigere Strompreise als wir sie
heute sehen und deshalb kümmern wir uns
jetzt genau darum das hinzukriegen zum
Beispiel auch indem wir jetzt
vorbereitet haben dass in den 30er
Jahren
gastkraftwerke die auch mit Wasserstoff
betrieben werden können dafür sorgen
dass wenn der Strom normalerweise aus
Windkraft Sonne Wasserkraft z.B kommt
aber es darin gerade fehlt wird dann
zusätzlich produzieren können all das
ist jetzt gerade auf dem Weg gebracht
aber das ganze sie haben kürzlich einen
erstaunlichen Satz gesagt den wir uns
mal anhören sollten das war kurz vor
ihrem Urlaub
meine Überzeugung ist wer zum Beispiel
Klimapolitik machen will muss sich
zutrauen dass jeder einzelne gesetzliche
Regelung in einer Volksabstimmung eine
Mehrheit fände
nun sagen uns aber im bildbarometer 57%
der Menschen also eine klare Mehrheit
ist die Klimapolitik der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung schadet das
heißt doch sie dürften zum Wohle der
Wirtschaft aktuell keine Klimapolitik
mehr machen nein ich bin aber überzeugt
dass man bei all den einzelnen Schritten
sich immer zutrauen muss die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger von denen konkret zu
überzeugen und ich bin aber 57 Prozent
sind nicht überzeugt viele sind in einer
Zeit des Umbruchs etwas unsicher deshalb
ist es ja auch wichtig dass wir über das
konkret reden was wir machen ich glaube
ein Gespräch mehr Klima weniger Klima
dann können wir jetzt eine halbe Stunde
hin und her reden ist auch oft schon
vorgekommen im Fernsehen und im Radio
und überall sonst aber in weit geht es
darum konkrete Sache Sachen wie viele
Windkraftanlagen müssen wir genehmigen
damit das klappt wie kriegen wir das
Tempo hin wir kriegen wir Tempo hin
damit die Stromleitung gebaut werden ich
will auf dieses Detail noch mal
zurückkommen wir haben heute eine große
Produktion von Windkraft und Windstrom
im Norden und Osten Deutschlands und
würden schon viele Probleme gelöst
hatten wenn dieser Strom nicht aber
durch Leitung in den Südwesten käme und
die bringen wir jetzt voran aber in der
Wirklichkeit war es so dass das
heizungsgesetz das hat ja die Diskussion
über Monate dominiert zu einem
dramatischen Ansehensverlust der
Ampelkoalition geführt die aktuelle Lage
beschreibt uns Andreas mal in 60
Sekunden
im zweiten Jahr seiner Kanzlerschaft ist
das Ansehen von Olaf Scholz auf einen
langen nicht gesehenen Tiefpunkt
gefallen Bundeskanzler Scholz setzt sich
in wichtigen politischen Fragen eher
nicht durch sagen 73% setzt sich durch
sagen nur 21 %. Deutschland fehlt es an
Wachstum an Arbeitskräften an gut
ausgebauter analoger Infrastruktur und
digitaler Infrastruktur an Vertrauen in
die Zukunft und in die Politik vor allem
das heizungsgesetz hat den Ruf der Ampel
ramponiert so wie diese Entscheidung
oder die ja immer noch nicht getroffene
Entscheidung kommuniziert worden ist war
das schlichteneingreifend ein Fiasko für
die Regierung als die ampelregierung
aufbrach lag die AFD bei zehn Prozent
sie hat sich bis zu diesem Sommer
verdoppelt die Partei des Kanzler ist
nun seit Wochen dahinter und auf einem
mehrjahres-
Bundeskanzler die Ampel ist weit weg von
einer eigenen Mehrheit in den Umfragen
fast dreiviertel der deutschen sagen uns
Sie Olaf Scholz könnten sich in
wichtigen politischen Fragen nicht
durchsetzen oder eher nicht durchsetzen
was folgt für Sie daraus erstmal ist die
Diagnose nicht zutreffend wir haben sehr
viele sehr konkrete Entscheidungen
getroffen tatsächlich ist das aber so
dass viele Sachen neu verhandelt werden
und das kriegen auch alle mit ich
wünschte mir dass das im Ton manchmal
anders stattfindet als es in der
Vergangenheit war und habe auch den
Eindruck dass über den Sommer sich viele
vorgenommen haben das genau zu ändern
sieht man ja das ist besser geworden ist
dann muntere ich alle dass sie das dann
fortsetzen wird aber schon weiter
gestritten das ist Diskussion gibt es
nicht ein Problem das wäre ja etwas
eigenwillig wenn es nicht so wäre aber
wir brauchen schon einen klaren Kurs den
man auch sehen kann und da bin ich
überzeugt dass wir genau das machen was
man für eine gute Zukunft in Deutschland
braucht und das das wenn es abgestimmt
wird nämlich bei Wahlen auch honoriert
wird
Nachrichten ansehen das heizungsgesetz
hat ja dem Ansehen der gesamten
Klimapolitik geschadet der Klimaforscher
lativ meinte sogar das Ford Klimaschutz
weil mittlerweile verbrannt hätten sie
nicht früher und härter eingreifen
müssen wir haben uns miteinander
verständigt und die Sachen diskutiert
das ist so gelaufen wie ich es eben
schon gesagt habe ein bisschen laut aus
meiner Sicht aber wir haben es jetzt
hingekriegt zwei
Vorhaben die wir hatten zusammenzuführen
und das ist auch glaube ich ein ganz
guter Schritt nach vorne nämlich einmal
eine kommunale wärmeplanung die wir
vorgesehen haben in all den über 11.000
Gemeinden Deutschlands den Landkreisen
die wichtig ist damit die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger wissen was kommt da demnächst
wenn Sie in den nächsten 20 Jahren mal
aufgerufen sind eine Entscheidung zu
treffen über die heizen für dieses
eigene Gebäude denn das ist ja für die
meisten gar nicht im nächsten und
übernächsten Jahr der Fall sondern
irgendwann mal bis 2045 und aus meiner
Sicht ist da ganz wichtig dass man weiß
bei mir um die Ecke da wird es demnächst
möglich sein dass ich mich an ein
Fernwärmenetz anschließen kann und wenn
die Gemeinde das mitgeteilt hat kann man
sich daran ja auch orientieren ein
wichtiges Thema dass die Bürger auch
beschäftigt ist der aktuell massive
Anstieg illegale Einreisen im
Politbarometer sagt uns eine Mehrheit
der Menschen Deutschland könne diese
Zahl der Flüchtlinge nicht verkraften
59% fordern schärfere Regelungen für die
Abschiebung ausreisepflichtige
Asylbewerber unterstützen sie eigentlich
die Überlegung ihrer Innenministerin zur
Verschärfung der abschiebe Regeln ja die
habe ich ja den Ländern vorgeschlagen
und wir haben das miteinander vereinbart
dass wir erstens die Ausländerbehörden
digitalisieren in sehr kurzer Zeit dass
wir für die Landesbehörden eine 24
Stunden Erreichbarkeit organisieren
demnächst dass wir dafür Sorge tragen
dass Georgien und Moldau als sicherer
Herkunftsländer anerkannt werden und
dass wir
an all den gesetzlichen Regelungen
arbeiten die es schwierig machen eine
durchzusetzende Abschiebung auch
durchzusetzen das hat sie als Paket
vorgeschlagen das feucht genau dieser
Linie und hat sie auch im Gespräch mit
vielen Praktikern in den Ländern
entwickelt das wird jetzt noch mal gegen
gecheckt in der Diskussion mit den
Ländern und dann bringen wir das auf den
gesetzgebungsweg wir müssen dringend
über ein Thema reden dass alle anderen
ja überschattete Krieg in der Ukraine
ihr aus München Berater war am
Wochenende in Saudi-Arabien zu den dort
stattfindenden
Friedensgesprächen haben diese Gespräche
nach ihrer Meinung eine ernsthafte
Chance der Anfang vom Ende des Kriegs zu
sein sie sind sehr wichtig und sie sind
wirklich erst der Anfang leider aber
trotzdem ist es was ganz Besonderes das
ist in Dänemark und dann jetzt in
Saudi-Arabien solche Gespräche auf der
Ebene der außenpolitischen Berater
stattgefunden haben dass jetzt noch mehr
Länder teilgenommen haben auch aus dem
aus Lateinamerika aus Afrika und aus
Asien auch China hat teilgenommen und
deshalb macht es Sinn dass wir diese
Gespräche fortsetzen weil sie ganz
konkret den Druck darauf erhöhen dass
Russland einsieht dass es ein falschen
Weg eingeschlagen hat und Truppen
zurückziehen muss und ein Frieden
möglich ist die Ukraine wiederum bittet
Deutschland seit geraumer Zeit um die
berühmten Taurus Marschflugkörper die
aber auch russisches Gebiet erreichen
könnten die Franzosen und die Briten
liefern schon ähnliche Waffen warum wir
nicht wir sind das Land das nach den USA
die Ukraine am meisten unterstützt wir
machen das vor allem jetzt mit
Artillerie wir haben das gemacht mit
sehr viel Luftverteidigung gerade heute
hat der ukrainische Präsident eine
Message abgesendet überall danke Olaf
gemeint ist natürlich Danke Deutschland
für die aktuellen Lieferung im Bereich
von Patriots zur Luftverteidigung
nochmal Frage gegangenheit werden wir
jede einzelne Entscheidung immer sehr
sorgfältig überprüfen was geht was Sinn
macht was unser Beitrag sein kann und
meinen Eindruck ist dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger das in der ganz großen
Mehrheit sehr sehr richtig finden das
nicht jedes Mal wenn einer irgendwo in
einer
irgendwo in einem Gespräch gefragt und
sagt das noch das noch dann immer gleich
gesagt und ja sondern dass wir uns
schwer machen wir werden es uns weiter
schwer machen dann würde das Ganze
übrigens hat in dem Projekt dass wir
abgefragt haben uns eine Mehrheit der
Menschen gesagt auf die Frage ob Olaf
Scholz bei politischen Interviews
häufiger als andere Politiker auch
Fragen keine konkreten Antworten gibt
haben uns 72% gesagt ja das stimmt das
war jetzt eben eine Scholz typische
Antwort aber noch mal konkret werden
antwortlicher Regierungschef gibt ja
nicht dazu da ist Pressekonferenzen zu
geben sondern das Land zu führen und das
heißt Entscheidung müssen immer
sorgfältig gewogen werden und das werde
ich weiter tun und das auch sehr klar
sagen oder wird mich auch keiner davon
abbringen wenn die Reichweite begrenzt
werden kann werden sie dann liefern wir
beschäftigen uns mit all den Fragen die
uns daran getragen werden und können
dann was dazu sagen wenn es etwas dazu
zu sagen gibt
noch eine Frage zum Schluss das kann ja
sein dass sie auf dem G20-Gipfel in
Indien jetzt im nächsten Monat Wladimir
Putin begegnen wie gehen sie als Mensch
Olaf Scholz nicht als Kanzler damit um
einen solchen schlechter zu treffen das
ist wirklich sehr bedrückend zu wissen
dass der russische Präsident ja der
derjenige ist der diesen Krieg
verursacht hat der deshalb natürlich
auch die Verantwortung dafür trägt das
unglaublich viele Menschen gestorben
sind in der Ukraine ukrainische Soldaten
Soldaten russische Soldaten Soldaten das
kann man nicht aus dem Kopf kriegen wenn
man so jemanden spricht und mit ihm
redet und das ist mir übrigens auch in
der Vergangenheit immer sehr bewusst
gewesen wenn ich mit ihm telefoniert
hatte geben Sie ihm dann beispielsweise
die Hand
ich finde das ist etwas was man dann
sich mal überlegen muss für mich geht's
nicht darum ob ich jemand die Hand gebe
oder nicht sondern ob ich klare Worte
finde und klare Forderungen habe und das
ist der Fall
obwohl das ganze herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch
das war unser sommerinterview mit dem
Bundeskanzler alle Antworten das bringt
mir extra finden Sie bei uns online in
der kommenden Woche trifft meine
Kollegen den SPD-Vorsitzenden das
klingen weil ihnen noch einen guten
Abend und eine gute Woche
[Musik]